hi there fellow adventurers I play
Arthur in a new film King Arthur legend
of the sword Guy Ritchie directs this
original tape on the legendary story of
King Arthur Arthur's journey takes him
from a boy living on the streets to a
man discovering his true destiny as king
when he learns to wield the mighty sword
Excalibur
the only thing standing in his way is my
character King vaulting so what happens
now you know what happens now the film
is an epic adventure full of incredible
battles and mythical creatures
now enjoy this exclusive clip brought to
you by Kino check sorry one of me I
haven't had a fight for years and I've
talked I'm happy to talk there is no way
I am fighting
I felt having the confidence that comes
with doing a lot of fight training it
does give one a certain spring in the
step from glint in the eye and so I
spent a lot of time in the gym just
doing fight training it wasn't as much
for the physical effect as the emotional
effect and the confidence that comes
with throwing a thousand punches a day
in terms of the actual physicality guy
and I talked a lot about that important
and interesting aspect of artha that he
had this sort of hunger to him that sort
of feral street kid starving wolf feel
and I were warming up Oh
Charlie Hunnam I just adore him I'll
tell you what's great BAM everything the
Charlie's have emerged he was asked to
he exudes a cockiness and a confidence
of a combination of treat lad bravado
but a certain amount of vulnerability as
well and we've asked him to do some
pretty tough stuff
the Charlie Hunnam is very organic so on
the day likes to gain the scene and feel
what the Sheen's like the kid is just
right there's nothing he can't there I
wouldn't say embarrasses Istanbul
because it indoors took a good few
knocks but um but charlie is so game and
so creative
we spent a stick that this has been by
far the best film experience that I've
ever had I've had a blast
[Applause]
you
why is the horse dropped there are
rumors the legend out that sort of a
king other than yourself find him
and now your story what kind of a man
would you become had you inherited your
father's Kingdom instead of being raised
in a brothel
or gave you such dry
[Music]
[Music]
he felt it didn't
the power
it was Fortune who murdered your father
but what you didn't account for is what
you can do with this sword we need to be
careful his power is increasing when
people fear you it is the most
intoxicating sensation land can possess
started recently you know longer I miss
I'm gonna kill him
pretty money way
you wanted the prophecy raised at four
so the people the power of Excalibur
you're playing with fire
but doesn't it make the palace burn well
there's the game
[Applause]